el boden y nos manda a este problema en
el foro de khan academy de facebook el
problema me pareció de un interés
general y por lo tanto vamos a
resolverlo el problema dice algo así
tengo la integral de 2 elevado a la
logaritmo natural de x todo esto
dividido entre x y todo esto
multiplicado a su vez por el diferencial
de x y ahí mismo en el foro el usuario
africana nos planteó una solución la
cual es correcta sin embargo el problema
me pareció tan interesante que lo quiero
resolver yo también
bueno pues tenemos esta integral y como
lo resuelvo lo primero que me doy cuenta
es que esto lo puedo escribir la
siguiente manera esto se ve un poco feo
y así se va a ver más claro tengo la
integral de uno entre x que multiplica a
2 elevado a la logaritmo natural de x
diferencial de x y por qué hago esto
porque yo sé que la derivada del
logaritmo natural de x es uno entre x
por lo tanto lo voy a escribir aquí
con respecto a x del logaritmo natural
de x es igual a 1 entre x que es justo
la función que tengo aquí al lado por lo
tanto es justo en este momento cuando se
me ocurre que esta integral a puede
resolver por sustitución u y bueno tú
puedes ponerle cualquier nombre que tú
quieras tú puedes decir la sustitución o
la s sustitución pero por convención se
usa
y bueno voy a llamar a igual a logaritmo
natural de x porque es la función a la
cual está elevada el 2 y eso es porque
tenemos la derivada multiplicando y
bueno por lo tanto si derivamos aún con
respecto a x esto es lo mismo que 1 / x
esto ya lo sabíamos y si lo ponemos en
forma diferencial me queda que la
derivada de v es igual a 1 entre x
diferencial de x y es justo esto lo que
voy a utilizar porque aquí ya hay muchas
cosas que podemos ver esto es lo mismo
que la integral y aquí que voy a
escribir al 2 elevado a la logaritmo
natural de x pero el logaritmo natural
de x acabamos de llamar o por lo tantos
2 elevado a la 1 y por otro lado tengo
uno entre x que multiplica el
diferencial de x que esto es
diferencial de un este y este va a ser
diferencial de v y lo voy a poner con
otro color muy bien vamos a empezar a
hacer esto colorido y ahora que se me
ocurre a bueno yo lo que sé es que esta
integral se parece muchísimo a unas
integrales que yo ya sé resolver que son
las integrales de la función exponencial
por lo tanto la idea que voy a utilizar
es tratar de resolver esto por la forma
de la función exponencial al final tanto
lae como el 2 son números aunque la es
un poco más irracional pero bueno lo que
sí sé es la integral del elevado en la x
lo voy a escribir aquí la integral de
elevado al x diferencial de x es lo
mismo que el elevado a la x más una
constante integración entonces
seguramente tú me vas a decir pues ya
acabamos esto es lo mismo que 2 elevado
la umma es una constante integración sin
embargo ten cuidado porque si ponemos
eso de solución estaríamos cometiendo un
grave error y ahorita tras dar cuenta
porque lo que voy a hacer en este caso
es escribir el número dos en base y como
escribo el número dos en base a bueno
pues el 2 es lo mismo que él
a logaritmo natural de 2 porque la
función exponencial y la función aritmos
se cancelan y entonces lo que daría que
he elevado a la logaritmo natural de 2
pues de simple y sencillamente 2 y de
hecho acabamos de encontrar una manera
alternativa para escribir cualquier
número cualquier número es lo mismo que
he elevado a la logaritmo natural de ese
mismo número y bueno ya que tengo esta
información entonces voy a sustituir a 2
entonces me quedan aquí lo voy a poner
que esto es lo mismo que la integral de
quien bueno de elevado a la logaritmo
natural de 2 todo esto es el 2 que tengo
aquí y esto a su vez está elevado a la 1
y todo esto diferencial de un muy bien y
ahora el siguiente paso es multiplicar
el logaritmo natural de 2 por 1 porque
hay una ley de los exponentes que dice
cuando tenemos un elemento algebraico
elevado a una potencia y después todo
eso elevado otra potencia las potencias
se multiplican y es lo que voy a
utilizar en este caso por lo tanto me va
a quedar la integral de elevada a la
logaritmo natural de 2 por un
diferencial de v esto por la ley de los
exponentes que les acabo de mencionar
recuerden que las potencias pasan
multiplicando y todo esto diferencial de
un y bueno ahora lo que quiero que se
den cuenta para el siguiente paso es que
tenemos un logaritmo natural de dos que
están multiplicando a la 1 por lo tanto
no podemos resolver esta integral luego
luego es muy parecida a ésta solamente
hay que tener cuidado porque la
diferencia es que no lo puedo hacer
directo
no puedo ser directo porque me estorba
el logaritmo natural de 2 es decir una
constante entonces yo voy a recordar una
fórmula alternativa que decía así la
integral de elevado a la que multiplica
a un diferencial de 1 es lo mismo que
uno entre a que multiplica al elevado a
la elevado a la más una constante de
integración y esto es porque si
derivamos elevado a la 'u' me queda am y
se multiplicó a por uno entre a me da
uno y por lo tanto ya tengo el anti
derivada y justo esto es lo que voy a
utilizar porque es una constante
entonces me va a quedar que tengo que
poner uno entre esa constante que en
este caso es el logaritmo natural de dos
entonces me queda uno entre el logaritmo
natural de dos que multiplica ha elevado
bueno primero va a estar elevado a la
función y nunca hay que olvidarla porque
esa es nuestra variable de integración
por lo tanto es lo primero que voy a
poner
y después también tenemos que estar x am
pero a en este caso era el logaritmo
natural de 2 por lo tanto voy a poner el
elevado la que multiplica a logaritmo
natural
lo único que hice fue cambiar la
multiplicación no hice nada raro y bueno
a todo esto hay que agregarle una
constante de integración y al menos ya
tengo la integral ya por fin resolví la
integral pero lo tengo en términos de un
entonces antes de pasar todo en términos
de muy variable original que en este
caso era la variable x lo que voy a
hacer es fijarse bien aquí porque puedo
escribir esto de una manera mucho más
sencilla
voy a recordar una propiedad de los
logaritmos que desea algo así esta ley
de los logaritmos dice que a x el
logaritmo natural de b
es lo mismo que el logaritmo natural de
b elevado a la i en este caso tengo algo
similar tengo u que multiplica a
logaritmo natural de 2 y bueno pues esto
sanz nuestra misma ley de los logaritmos
me queda que es lo mismo que el
logaritmo natural de 2 elevado a la 'u'
por lo tanto voy a usar esa propiedad y
me queda que esto es lo mismo que uno
entre el logaritmo natural de 2 que
multiplica a elevado a la logaritmo
natural de 2 elevado a la u
esto por la propiedad que acabo de ver
más una constante integración y bueno
escribí esto de esta forma porque él
voy a modificar lo que quiero que
piensen ahorita es cuál es el término el
cual es igual ha elevado a la logar de
natural de 2 elevado a su vez al agua y
esto es ni más ni menos que 2 elevado a
la uv esto lo vimos hace ratito lo
tenemos aquí arriba y es la misma
propiedad entonces me queda uno entre el
logaritmo natural de 2 que multiplica a
2 elevado al agua esto por lo que
acabamos de ver acá arriba no lo olviden
lo voy a escribir aquí a es lo mismo que
elevado a logaritmo natural de a y ya es
cualquier número es una forma
alternativa de escribir cualquier número
por lo tanto en este caso es el 2 y
bueno me queda esto más una constante de
integración y ya acabamos no no hemos
acabado
hay que regresar todo a la variable
original es decir hacer la sustitución
hacia atrás y para eso lo que necesito
hacer es escribir en términos de x pero
es igual a logaritmo natural de x por lo
tanto esto es lo mismo
y ahora sí para poner la respuesta
correcta voy a escribir todo yo tenía
que la integral de 2 elevado a logaritmo
natural de x todo esto entre x
diferencial de x es igual y ahora si me
queda que va a ser igual a 1 entre el
logaritmo natural de 2 1 entre el
logaritmo natural de 2 y sustituyendo
aún me queda que esto multiplica a 2 que
está elevado a logaritmo natural de x
más una constante de integración y ya
está hemos resuelto este problema así
que muchas gracias a voten y por
mandarnos este problema y los invito a
que sigan mandando problemas en los
foros de cannes academy